it's all about you the police didn't
want this protest to happen they banned
it only for the course to rule it can go
ahead but with strict limits on numbers
only 19 people were allowed to take part
this is not a gamma we signed on for
this is not a Democrats we know our
courts have been part of those who are
trying to suppress this country and
someday they will bow their heads down
in shape but this small March is a sign
of larger discontent
Ghana's currency is plummeted against
the dollar this past year that's pushed
up the price of imports at a time when
inflation is already high food and fuel
prices have more than doubled we can't
do anything if we go to the market
whatever you have whatever amount you
have you can't buy anything in the
market the system is so hot people have
to check and and then look at how the
dollar is moving faster it's affecting
business it's affecting almost
everything in this country protesters
say corruption and bad policies have
caused the crisis a broad Coalition of
opposition groups and activists are
putting pressure on the government to
come up with Solutions this is the
beginning of many many protests to come
if the conditions do not improve we will
make the country ungovernable president
Nana addo has been holding talks with
Business Leaders to find a way to get
the economy back on track but on the
streets life is getting harder and
patience is wearing thin
Vincent Monaghan Al Jazeera